and it's me bruno oliveira works who
did not have the name here of the android and its
grandson and working here with
android in Brazil is our job is
prohibited by legislation then to whom
do not know we're trained by
alexandre cenci but our work is
make sure you are happy, you are
our developers and if you do not
are happy with the platform we are
doing a good job
if you are not happy with the
platform but we are not making a
Good job, so our job is
just talk to you know the
that is leaving the happy or not
and to make sure that everyone
had a good experience
oh I'm transmitting this here is the
our android studio here has maintained or
do not have among all things in our
This business said nery
in fact he spoke in it independently
Are you on time or not?
china controls sun he goes
permanently writer is but always
that appears on the screen is a place to people
It's shit so by definition it's
working right here at khan's house in
suggestive name our new office of
Sao Paulo with some people to
interview and in the subjects that came
see this is in other magazines
We are count, it has turned brown and hot.
directly cast the cane juice
chose a theme well see Brazilian will
characterize this transmission of
national legal
well, let's get started now I noticed
that I was playing with the product shirt
wrong to know that I should have called
in medical wardrobes but anyway
space will see now compete with
the right product shirt
almost barely perceptible in what was a
Last moment correction is good, right?
so we're here to talk about
android development for this to
people have here our list of
Questions that it is raining
public where you could make your
questions
So I think we can start.
or picking up the questions and seeing which
are the ones that we can
answer questions
the first one is I wonder if
is pedro fsn from goiânia
Is he asking me? Would you like to know if there is
about the possible solution with the
to the previous rigor
about the use of lead in androids
I have already used the solution of the
gecoc would like to know google solutions
then the one to whom only to upgrade
Why are not you following along?
last goal last year
we have an interest in everybody
saying that we were working
in a fight or a fight
compatible version of chumbar
with all versions to this day whites is
I remember that because I did this
promise is to say it was not in my
session of this promise was made
so now you have to fulfill it, it's just that
to take action to function in the
previous versions
what we have today does not have a
official google solution yet
if you want to use chumbar you need
have at least connecting top
and if you mean that if you want
use more previous campaigns
a very good solution that was made
by gecoc in this solution call itself
schumacher ó is essentially a cheerful
that you include in your project and it
allows you to use chumbar in the tests
previous android
so the question is when google goes
launch the version itself is not closed
Are you working on it?
in fact it's the center of the guy's side
what are you working on then I found
that things are progressing but it is
It's hard for us to know when it's going
to have available is because it's what I
I always play engineering.
three dates, that's what you have today and never
then it means that in the future it will
happen in the future
I hope it's soon but it's too much.
it will hardly ever be a school day
but a kick at least one day of the week
even though it's hard could not paste
is arrested
but then I thought it could only be
understand with this framework of discussion
with the people of my Brazil
He can say exactly that.
Unfortunately, there is no date to see if
This is a solution that only
each one must choose our own here
here it fits most try to solve the
North smell, right?
the very good solution you have in lime
at the discretion of each one who would like to
use and also have nothing nothing obliges you
To use to leave, then, for example,
some applications that we have more
simple example if you are using
plus a bar that only has two exceptions
application title buttons is perhaps
You do not even have to do all this
complication of wanting to use sherlock
For sure you may as well say it is not
it's no problem, you try
to jump on the basic rate until
I got there with two buttons since the
appearance is something connected to the
user since it guides them easily
that's an equivalent to the show bar
for example there is no problem
with it's own methods that
He is also the father of Laila.
but you do not always have to use
all dogs if you can doubt their
application the shared call is
a thing that is not to be woven into
angola of each one the way that I am
daring then you can leave it leaves
wow, what
the call is one of the first regions
more fights and probably used
can benefit the application and
In addition, it is worth noting that
people already helped you are when people
launched the e-mail education plan already
is being trained to use the interface
application is to use skype will
get even stronger from them app
the user wants the user is he
learn
he learns with applications he learns
using then if since you bought the
android device he is he is
using google apps using
applications that use one more bar
so he is under training
intensive there and learning the sax
bar and learning that those buttons
to do such thing is that
the other thing then if you use chumbar
Are you joining this pattern?
then you will automatically know how to use
app
so it's something I always say
Here for who does this for long.
We already had share but the reservation
this user experience thing is
extremely important this does not
should be underestimated
if the user needs to read a book to
learning to use the application is
doing wrong
an experiment that I always thought
the time is the next before you
launch the application is to give your
application with laymen you already know what
they knew they did not understand anything about
code with that smile what I think
things are savior within
word processor
So, take this guy, lend it to you.
android for he hopes to use the application
to stop writing what the application
do it and you want to write how to do it
some things if he gets the look with
a question mark is because you
need to improve a little by your
interface unless of course your
goal be they had for geeks
educational nerds
it's okay but it's always important you
make sure your entire target audience
your app and sometimes funny is
As we as the victory has something that
shocks it like this, but it's obvious that
you stay flat will detail the deal
but the new one to produce other users
There are things that are very obvious to us.
as a citizen user and I do not have
no doubt of what is going to happen
I think he can move on to the next
ask the question live the staff
here you go in galt if you can
ask the question by doing what leaves the
board shows android versions only
I think mclaren and world fashion
is a way of knowing for example that
type of record is being posted in the
Brazil in determined there changes of country
most emergent or even android level
for simpler devices to this
question
whether or not the strategy brings this
question obviously the following this is
a strategy that we generally
recommends that you have met the users
I do not think your users are you know
what android versions are using to
you prioritize issues
right are not
so it is important to have
precisely this concern with the
distribution of androids on the market
you want to achieve
Unfortunately we do not have the sport.
of the country to this is something I think
extremely useful indeed is but it is a
thing that we do not currently have
this statistic is computed
globally and I do not know if for a
difficulty in understanding which
country ends android but anyway I do not know
the fact is that they only have this
statistics in a world-wide way.
specifically in the case of Brazil, which
I've seen too much that I need
does not deviate much from that statistic
world in Brazil we do not have
has a very very different market
of the world statistics you see
currently if you look at the other
stores you can see that it is extremely
important that it stays of the day
strike up at least if you
can make it work was 2.2 is a
bonus but you about evolution
functional upwards you already
rate as well as almost
percentage to say
the massive percentage of the market
potential is and there are because there
types of applications or those that
They do not want to make money.
those whose goal is to bring a
user information or enable the
access to services and those who want
to make money, then to those
goals that want to make money with
one is how the neighborhood is this slice of
users who have been down and door
less and less because the next
to see if you would care in direct
up
Are you? You get more than 90% of the
devices and you can also
a much larger percentage of
income is a much larger percentage given
an attachment that happens with each
successive version the collective android
annual per user, for example if
look at real monetization per user
are you getting a gérin device?
this is much higher than the actual
user on the device you have to
It was a mistake, it was a mistake.
then it means if the objective of winning
money with your application is always
The more interesting you use pleasure
for the newer versions of the Android
that older people
Of course this is clear if you have the
an engineering reception but the case the
best case scenario is if you are
optimize for all devices and
personal observation that is
Excuse has not flowed and it's cool you already
made it look like the newer versions
and use the medicine only ask more
educational in the newest and most
have the oldest profile if it is
better you appear more modern than
you look older than your
contract
sometimes I can follow the patterns
new
you should as far as possible always
that the patterns that are there always use
with a weak for example is because despite
We're very focused on Brazil.
of an ovi service in Brazil but has to
remember that the global apps market is
so many people who do not like the
your asset the more you have better
makes a big difference when it comes to
do this to give success over the
application also in particular and
to bear all this is one thing
very important because sometimes
is developing we think the
user will have seen in our life
on the screen like that
but suddenly he's pulling out a screen
Thus was born the 17
so we here is a brutal difference
Annex 4, annex 7 at that time.
one thing that looks very complex 4 is
It may seem a little less good.
more successful and certainly more
you pick up your nexus 4g interface
phone play it only do is
Resize the tablet size
you are doing here you are
wasting user money is
because the user pays dearly to have a
tablet
he paid dearly for all those pixels
so suddenly you're using all
the pixels he paid dearly for a
interface as long as the pt does
smaller
then for the best user experience
it's always good to have your app it
can use the tablet screen
an intelligent and used way was the
Next stretch is not catching you all
have a cell phone and make the source bigger is
the users did not confront the study is
because they are free
they buy tavares because they want
a larger screen space utilization
better the space of land
for example if you have a spiral of
a mobile TV that has a
list of things and then another screen
which details
suddenly no tablet defending your
content makes sense you make two
vacancies
you put a piece of
left that has what's on your list
of items and in the right fragmentation
the details is obviously a solution
works for all apps then entire
in a single example then depending on the
complexity of the data you display
can do so may make sense or
no and and there was also the boss 10 no
has this 10-inch tablet is that
they are significant but
significantly larger than your
cell phone
I'll make the size compared to cnaa in
at least five times the other air
side then you surely get your
interface and make them reach the
this size
It's going to be a house so it's very
It is important for you to think about it when
also develop one of the non-financial
Call people you can only use with
Your top address has a champion of everything.
and against all are able to insure
so a second a form and also
show one more way to hold for such
different motif then usability and the
ex is not just images resize the
size and larger fonts since
the other thing is a very common mistake
also reminds us that the resolution
other modern devices is very
great for example in the four
325 cpi
so if you have a cell phone once
oldest has 160gb episode for
trying to talk about the perfect lack can
see the small intact perfect in
my screen is over or are great but
You'll be running a newer device.
and then you notice that the resolution of the
graphic is not constructive enough
this gives a horrible feeling of a
daughter of a little professional clarifies
that the discount in time is seeing a
page to 90's page knows those
pages will keep costs and
immense size is then it is always
important, I'm sure that
Are you using one more?
that it is compatible with the devices
more modern
and I think I'll pass the next question
in the attack of the electoral Sunday and
even more iran
so the question here from the south was ewerton
of prudent president against the
brunet grandson, I would like you to speak
a little about frequency only and I moved
lightning down next best
practices for the existence of objects
could not be the first officer
Thank you for the same work, this is
this subject has not yet discovered which
best libero in the world so I guess
he will live for some decades with
a fairly large competition between the
different buses and would be the people
could have a renovation could in
theory
Only if we do one does not seek
did not want to make or put a solution
as official seat for everyone's strength
everybody used because who will know
if these people really know how to do it
avaí is in fact what is best to have a
open community with the following you
can have this competition between
different rmc ever better choose
It is best to have a situation
depends on it will put a
For you, you make inputs for me.
Do not answer because you're not with
I have never seen a business there.
You'll have to do it again.
to launch another trailer and people
also danced time doing something
that even if it really promises to be
does not mean it's going to be a
solution in a group
complicated to come up in a few kind
by default this is really complicated
then the ideal is the following everything that is
whether it's official or things that are
Platform Essentials and things that
are important to other things to
other things to be developed in
top
in the case of today I think that the
freedom you have to use any
rm and this freedom precisely from the
compete for equal
is a very productive thing at the time.
system is difficult to answer
What network is right for is provocative?
you know in depth what the application
does
it's certainly not so it's important you
choose that it is appropriate for
every application is forever person
the musician is bring the android already comes with the
sql so at least so is the basics
which is the sql and obviously is very
far from being one and less during the
falls already comes with an already built-in
nuno andrade then for most of the
that are simpler and pensions
lj
but you really need to use one on the
mpe is then in this case you have to
really select h1n1 to be more
This is particularly
simple humble frei ruiz and in general
So Portuguese is this question of the
It's worth a little bit with the frei but he messes
appears as for example a framework of
dependency management systems can use
It's something I always said when
student stayed overnight when I saw nothing
I've seen and other mobile technologies that
You talk about frankfurt is already over
generating other things in your
application and that this may not suddenly
had something have you use
freak mister worth getting the premium do
a test to see if that little man
happened articles that planned 11 for
example an unnecessary layer of your
app
I always think of every activity
the furniture but the nexus
four other rivals are capable
of excellent processing device
which has its limitations in the then much
be careful when selecting a
flashback and tests and more tests are
always welcome also has another
problem also with the indiscriminate use of
the rn is the following can not be tempting
because it's easier, it's easier to see the
code you pick up and save all
objects do not get caught by your application
whole state takes all objects that
you have and save as a strategy
similar I checked and you take all eight
shot shots of the state of all
objects and all relationships between
they won in the file is when you
you load this file
this may work well for the
computer is not only a reminder of people and
a mobile device first
access to the author where it is more or less
slow and expensive then if every time the
lord who starts will be charged 1 gb
storage data but slow
then you're also using a lot of cpu
the user will notice that he has problem with
your lithium's battery consumption then
is dangerous because precisely these
clouds objects you would say in applications
sometimes they get out of control
especially you forget to do
comply on foot
And by the way, you're rolling trash
example things that have been deleted
still faced by one thing is
when you save cloud with objects
they get taken in there so it's important
remember that the other mobile despite
having a fast government is still a
limited form in comparison to the
desktop is then also excreted
asked mom too so now it's like
make a change what you want to do
a comment to the question nothing in the backpack
that the sun was encouraged to ask a question
who does not carry a backpack but the backpacks
eagles that win the next right
so I think you can bypass
backpack for any google make a
prediction of when ronaldo will work
all those available in other countries
not be taken, for example, to seek
as well as sound feedback
in other languages ​​it's soooo the newspaper
he currently has many expensive works
usually united because it ends up launching
carlos pinheiro that is well and
remembered the pastor is not relevant to people
will expand the world
things on the I know the newspaper here
considers ronaldo to be a
very important product to do everything
Brazil considers alcohol to be a
central element of the android in the final is
that tool that understands the most
user learns from the user but
I understand the user and it is the one that in
theory becomes more and more
more suggestions but other users
this means of course that you need
appropriate cards for each country in the
However, the cards are played by
but they have cards that are
the country here for example
has stayed with the games
baseball and football focuses on
other forums that I do not do
minimum idea of ​​how to play and not right
but I just know it's the whole world is going to be
an integer and just put the plus
would be high forest for example not
had the same thing implemented to
National soccer clubs is the one I know
that the team is also committed to
become more and more international
but it is quite difficult to tapas are one thing
only and not reliable engineering
I've been on good projects in
out of the way to speak with certainty that
will launch national skates date x more
five aspirants will yes but it is necessary
martins
this happens not as the lack of
planning but because the market is a
very dynamic thing so it's one thing is
talk football but the UN where you speak
mobile things change very fast no
it was zero hour ahead of time what
is a priority for all but behind
suddenly ceases to be a priority
there are no dates for the ministry
in which if not I will not count on six
conditions there but it's not going to work
mystery or lack of planning
which is really the achievement of the right
to learn these things then to us
Do not mind it, it's not even better, it's just the date.
that
but what I know that rural is very
important a central square of our
strategy is certainly to etc. and the scope
global android also another piece
strategy but we will combine
both
there was a cultural here is very
important to have a tablet or not
working this time the source the
good countries
there is someone here asking whether or not it is legal
The hand is just a question, same name.
but developed android only
I did not have world developed all
planet outside our ruined burg
the world is an excellent question is this
question is very very relevant because
therefore it is difficult to know where the
angle
we all means we live in the cloud
for example
this is a question we always had
several products here where it is
developed on these shores asp world
physical or less relevant to zero or
android is developed from behind in
money
the engineer who happens to be
already composed tubes but by chance used
they are here kept but have some
money for using all others
places of the world but what I
which imports 90 the code that produces
then sometimes for example engineers
have described coke trams are
here we have to have a team of
good part of this andrade money lives
in london for the moving part zurich a
I myself worked with android and
jackson and things for android it
I was working in Brazil.
that is, the physical location has a
income will be more or less reduced
for these engineering things but
Always insist boot off when you are
most of the gold that lives the largest
part of the money because of work
android
I think it's a partner so I
I do not know if it's like this.
surrounding area, we have other
Engineering wins also in the states
united and on components android
are shared with the products they have
as it has components that are
entire group and each time it developed
with different teams received from a
different way of the world then it's
It's difficult to answer a question where
products developed in a diagram of
faith but I think most of the
androids and is developed here without
consider the components are
shared
we can no longer separate the cheap vapor
or less ok but mauro pedro would like to
make experience of the list similar to
the goal scored against you with animations
notable change uses mask
horizontal view of varzim sat
for him there is an example with this and
max is what should make the payment of the
damn it
ok let's see what my client is
are the main reasons one thing
these career here is me too.
first time I tried to make a list
with graphics do not know how much I expected
to do it there on care
did not expect to make 5 the selected list
the necklace and you see no show in the
the first time she went from
shooting in 51 of the mayors is
because it happens when you put
thanks to the land in all operations
more delicious on an android device
if you do not put graphics on the screen a
efficiently graphics in law while
try it this way gets bad
for example one of the common mistakes is you
do not make a box of stairs then
when you make one of these lists in the
example uses needles is not because you
have on google
stone he sent the city brought some
years off the screen while others
simply entering the screen and what
happens when the help has come up
is that those elements that you that
just leave the screen can not return to
happen and will never return to power
But I need to write, you decide if
You did not solve this, certainly.
Slow down if you when you draw
you determine which of these are
graphics now on the screen and if you
have not you been loaded on that will
happen you will have that experience that
the team becomes economical the paradigms to
new good experience
The first strategy is to use the cash
you make a pipe and a cigar and all
Once you load you leave it saved.
in the box until the box more space then the
box he has he got that concept
money
the display is not always that you have to
Put a box thing on it
space you will do the eviction of a
90 the criterion of admission defense of the team
of the cachets were box in the middle of a
dog you'll take the box here from
which was - recently use the image that
You did not even show up to feel
scarf in an image box
will certainly improve the
performance
Another thing the following is to make predictions
is if the user is rolling the screen in the
secretary has shown a certain
speed is more or less easy to predict
that it will need several images
so follow then you can already do
perfex you can exit loading of
soccer
your cache for the singer arrives there and
chance to win is something else
important is not to force the oil
redoing this is a little sometimes it's
easy and it's easy to get that many
times
the following when you are using this
the list of atp he make a movie for
you recite then this date is the
technological training and education as
make this picture
so instead of creating a new one every time
that a mechanism he spends a bingo
beneficent of your old ones to you
can pick up and convert it predicted that
it works at that time
There are a lot of people that have a lot of developers.
which is not ecological and still plays
We listened to the previous one and wanted a good but if
You did not see the new one besides you
trash in memory
You're going to have a very slow goal.
because I remember garbage is not free
the collection of garbage subject to the
collection wherever you spoke with
zero hour you lose a little bit of
application performance
if you are just constantly being
a garbage generating machine
then it will certainly have a
performance has been reduced then if you
enjoy the cold that came to you
do a recycling
performance works best for you
Check here only that you will have a
problem that tragically betray the
trap
if you are re-use and civil
way to change his hotel is for
behind the chicken is to take a step back from
layout
he has to play the role every time
who is going to show a view is you will have
a performance too then you
you have to be careful to keep the same
layout and not make
is and is visible or invisible with the
athletic go but you need to take items
visible and invisible
never because when you make a goal at
he needs to get the one in there.
hierarchy when he was 11 years old read
what can do the layout
so it is important to be careful with
this is particularly so your code
to reuse vilta very complicated
it's his chance he's trying we need
of an elton partner is very large
so that's what I always get
simplify as much as possible
reuse code saw if you
need several different types in the
your list you may have different you
date registered and look only goes
appropriate time to call
appropriate so you never try
reuse oil of type x to make
a red wine always moving
type x and y prophetic are without ever
try to convert the two and certainly
will improve the items in the
list
Another thing is the following lists
rarely are the example lists
that items 123456 in the Hawaiian
useful lists have data that are pulled
disclose if you have a list because
has content this content is being
probably downloaded from the internet.
internet a file to another place
and you have to be careful with just
with this part of loading the contents of
other place what can happen if you
is loading content from elsewhere
here is taking this step of
content elsewhere than
is holding your performance
so for example you are finding the
your server something can be
servers is clean at that time is
impossible to foresee in the law because of
Your talent list is with another
What in here is what you always do
a fred will not have the ong who cares
of this bureaucratic part of and to the
consumer to take pictures is this part of
always have to be done with a
another thirst never make a better fred
thing that is very heavy what
involve trips to him and why this
in the network said that always slow then
never on premiere and fred has to
worry only one thing that is the
most central component of your creative
that users
the premiere that the user's butler
then the user with the user is in the
finger to a referendum detect there she does not
can be engaged in something else and
nothing more important to one side of the
eyes so if you're carrying it gives
Some of the internet does a fraud
election and what will happen in the worst
of the cases the user 10 pro arrives at
Image
you have not uploaded yet is the is not the list
gonna lock you have to continue
making the goals only you do not show the
image shows some country or from there
Wow, what are you doing well?
Rodrigo inspires that little thing expires
that generates is and still needs to study more
psychology because I do not understand it yet
but one thing I always say is that it is
very strange effect that when the
user sees something spinning from staying
calm
then you think the process is
slow and suddenly you put it on
this thing that turns on the screen he was
directed against her will ask that he not
Do you think you're dating?
so it's important when you have a
image and loading leave blank
If you leave the blank hour goes
have training this farm and gave paulo
the last scene within the
environment is exactly it will know that
he will despair of the eyes if
desperate to see easily then
you put the tires will not have a
will you have more patience, will he know?
everything that inspires you because you have
very cool thing is going to happen
shortly
so it's important to you from spe
with the user and something else if you notice
if your experience is that the user has
What do you keep looking at waiting all the time?
so there's something wrong with some
another component of the native blood by
example if you depend a lot on these
graphics sale time
I just do not think it makes sense without
exactly worth investing in
server is a bit faster to
it would return user graph but
recalls that the most precious resource
you have more expensive is the patience of the
user
You do not want to spend
The user you do not need is much
better of this real why spend for
your users
then we must have you not too
download to 5 in the images as
put if you have to take
conquering adapter has one thing that the
the size of the visa it displays on the screen
the size of elements on your list has
huh
it will use the non-element
are on the screen but you can already be a
father for example and shot is weird
which will simultaneously
pictures making you think
locally there only remembering that images
not very fond of bitmaps acting
immutable business and carried an hour
Most importantly, the government is
great but it's also important to have
mobilized against the Flemish I had many
problems
Of course I never told
very low forget that there is 11 on the river
android has a clash to the part of the
application is part of the routine and if you
download too much application bitmaps can
being with low memory usage will be
very good if you have delivered you will
have a fatally provocative problem
so think about strategies of your
frame is very complicated racked
twitter something wrong maybe there
is getting too much because also
I think the strategy is favor is by
love of god keep this loading
the athletes away from their tragedy that
will draw the user list
This is very important indeed and back there
to be displayed on the screen searches for 20
jets for tragedy but the input
has several solutions or the tea with
mainly low
product catalog image
places with five important ones you
do this simultaneously in three
modalities to seek a little warned
the user will always have the slightest idea
The important thing is that there we remember.
this all in galt but it's because that
really really important is the
Another important thing is the
following the world currently suffers from
the problem of megapixel inflation in the
then even the camera plus that camera
cheaper on the market shelves
take pictures of him and many
megapixels gift much faster than
You really wanna use only have
for example that photo that photo of
a product that had a photo of the pot of
yogurt is that photo has 12 megapixels
because you need to see the almost more
used on twitter williams
so what happens when images
they are usually much larger than
you really need it especially in
a screen in the neighborhood
if you take a mobile screen here you
make image that size is and you will
carrying a 12-megapixel image
for what you're spending a lot of
memory waiting a lot but very much
a lot of memory is then
I am important is to load 120 maps of
according to you will need this too
It's not immediate and you're not alone.
makes new max papis and only loads with
bishop you will load the image in the
full resolution of them you have jr of 12
megapixels and yogurt and you will put
in a window but nothing that nobody wins
You use your lip only the way you do.
he come you're carrying 12
megapixels to compress after 2
megapixels but not even then and this
memory is we thanks boness is talking
there is a limit is the limit and not much
generous than when the memory of
bike you can carry the
android application so if you put
two of these groups is one more apple
all with 14 megapixels you
will probably end this
It improves very fast so it's talk
staff is warm about your company and
usually from the south or by doing
questions so have staff doing what
before descending image generates pressures
such as neighborhoods where the same
have to make these accounts because of the
size of a good but do it already
less 12 megapixels than
you can download in several is not a
good practice is an excellent practice you
has more adapted with the father already leaves the
even if you are the
neighborhood
now if you have no image used
for mobile, for example you have a
image what the user got the camera
for example you allow the user
take a picture with the camera projectors
something of your game
so the game has a user avatar and
I prefer that he use the image he
take an auto stitch and put a
lift this self photo of the user take
probably it has a device
android that has a camera is this and if
this camera has at least 15 thousand
people in the eyes on the modern
some prosecutors is much more
example that only has 8 megapixels so
Who could play your game and I'll see
Even cool, I can put my own
photo as retail
so it's cool, I want to take a picture of me
even with the front camera for the attack
the four a front camera
only that the front camera means either the
rear camera that has even more than the
solution still does not take a photo and
I suddenly pass by a teacher to
your app is a huge lack of 8
megapixels to my face with all
wines etc then
of 8 megapixels huge so if you have
this in the file is a jr
How do you do in this case on you?
obviously you will not ask the user
does not remember the convenience only the user
Please, take a photo of your face.
Encourage to get the time is you do not
Are you going to say that?
so you have to work with what?
you think there's that 8-image
megapixels to my face you have to
do is turn it into an image
small so that you could
load in memory resize after
throw away
only this is not enough the best
Way You Make It Already
always count if you look
sbt at the time has something called
hebe factors
if you look at the options
her payment you can pass it on to her
is called cécé with sites or century in
2008 the next if you pass 2 it goes
load one in 2 pixels
if you happen to be by law 4 goes
one person in four
which means you can first
medimagem this you can do also the
well done and you have another option that you
load image size
Our first try loading the image.
only with the size this will cause that
the image is not loaded unless you
will know what the
dimensions in images you will know that
That image of my face is 14
megapixels and type 3 thousand and 2 thousand
so based on that you calculate which
also what you need like you
also calculate that you need
Do you know the resolution of your
device and spoke at the end of the
screen
so if you know these two things
you can do a simple math
you will find that the image you
you need 300 to 200
if you know you have 300 thousand two hundred and
original image is from 3 thousand to 2 thousand
so you do another simple math
8 and 10
so you need for every ten people
who have the image of one then you pass
gives it a flavor of 10 of the bush product and
you upload an image already directly
of memory that is already the right size
for you to show your application and
you do not waste now any
so this is a very very technical
important if you take an image that
It was not you, it was what you got
something was missing
I do not think this part is that
just be careful because sometimes you
will load eui-sun thing I already
I committed if you upload the image and how much
will carry both in size we are
carry the whole team to remember
even if you carry the team
all
you will always carry the goal of the other
so the same tone always broke the
music you uploaded before the image
from yeda here the hills the image
Then everything is only decided.
Another important thing is the following
times in java
program and I have already left
people have the impression that everything has
to be abstract right?
I have seen, for example, implementations of
java things that are like this instead of
have only one thing I have another
thing is not almost the right kind and that
creates another class that creates a
interface interface implements four
different interfaces you create one of
leather encoder you create a sound that
implementation there you are the downgrade
four other interfaces to it that the
object that is one that cleiton and 50 eu
we created the 500 foreign mall in
subject that instance and diseases you
have to do is leave her alone there
parameters and then you take those
I mean, well, you can do that.
to argue that this is very good for the
code organization for collaboration
team is only certain that the place of
to do all are common to all
certainly not equal and fred in that
moment you're going to draw something
if you can find out what you think you have
what draw do you need to write the
100-line code and place and place
a price around that and deal with 50
different types of exception
surely that your receiving code
then this java already exists in this
temptation to do abstract things
It's really when you're there when you
You need something with a lot of
performance sometimes is much better kiss
do this situation all you do something
simple as for example equal pains
so this does not have any problem in
to do the same 2 is even if two is not
an abstract representation of everything that
you have to do it, but when you have
that piece of rope you know you have
that being is having a very
great
It's okay, you make some shortcuts.
It will not show all of you someday.
need to use another type of 2 you
had not thought before
if maths invent a new type of
all
so you can modify your code only
This must happen, but it's you.
prematurely use to say undo
everything extremely abstract so that
never having to modify the code says
The only thing that's going to happen here
you will get into your account from the slow and
you'll have to modify your code
when many things change because the
chance is that this observation
covers that need that goes
appear in the future so be careful
these abstractions are simple
clear that the application that does not
You must have that you do not have to have
performance, how are you? a little more
abstract because it's a good practice you
do not leave too much rodrigues to
good practice is your own
for the future of the project but it is a code
you need to run fast
It's better that it be simpler than that.
was strictly related to the
Sometimes crimes are something we use
half without thinking much more strange is
expensive
for example if you are once wrote
method that is that jumped screen with guess
that I choose her something to
do high score and see for myself
converted normal because I wanted to
formatting especially I would get every
every number and make a stranger the
number puts on screen that happened 10
frames per second
but as it should be the second type the
game was taking so long to
to return to school while he was
taking forever to render everything in the
your screen because what happens when
You'll buy another 30 already generating
trash, right?
so why do you get a sling?
which is number 1 was there that is created
other 30 the number 2 you join
when you put together and create a third
expires in 2012 and throws out the two
other stars you get the number three if
they add that it's more a star he
created in memory
after joining the other two wanted
a new strang remembers forever only are
immutable was unable to modify the
stream
so if I next to en125 and 3 he is
wanting a new star that is 123
then played out a two and three
so I do it all holy frame by
a high score that has five digits
It's a lot of trash right so it's always good
be careful about this excessive generation
it's not just because I already take it
trash bill for you that means
What do you have is that you neglect it?
so not only are several other
things so always use more attention
to see how much garbage is being generated
your jams soup
required very carefully
only who is listening is not here
not only to remember that we have people who
commented that not being able to enter is
closed there is a limit of participants and
one in galt then we try central
the customers reaching you can not
enter more people are participating
It's tart with casting away cast a
people had a little time in the world
even renault same time tries to
new next time they will become one more
you little you can enchant the world
I just wanted to enjoy that we're
In the final 15 minutes there, it's up to you.
do not talk to the folks who pick up your
Galt to leave positions that are of
communities
On the contrary, I forgot, we are
creating even more of Jesus in the
Brazil and we consume July 14 six
or seven days in campinas in salvador vai
to go out paulo and reef also in blumenau
Santa Catarina
no one is actively in the community
of time the food group had been
starting work here in brazil had
transition time
one of the things that has very cool the
staff sees that they must exist in
version that is the team where it is
analysis of some applications is not
and thus make it more the latter the
ideas on what to do with the
staff there
simply grabbed some apps and
analyze the application of a sanction
30 40 minutes or up to an hour people
wants to help you make an app
of quality and android we have
many apps you want to improve
as indicative of you as the
People want to do this by acting
more direct in goal in cups than this
agreement has more difficulty and
example first common point had
the question of navigation of the
application is that it messes up
the doubts that I observe cheese as
the sax a bar of some elements
I wanted to give a sign to
You guys, not in the next days.
or next week you should open a
consumption formula also submitted the
applications that want us to give
navigation text and the
people will also show the apps
example are some applications that the
People are referring here in Brazil
including applications that
having recently emphasized again that
sing captives with the urban fish
that we work together
with manson and help improve on
Do you work with you, too?
It's soon we will announce more
some of us do not have
unfortunately when fixed issue of
trips and times played here are
This year we will have more fests
are also connected dgs there is the
People are going to do some more
mainly steps to win
specific points and make an analysis
more specific as you do in the
navigation such that anyone who has any
personal suggestion may change in the
google plus in mexico in the other paper until
more on this commented today we will
try as far as possible to respond
for you 11 personal satisfaction as
curious and what would be the next
steps our world well my mine
make a comment in the meantime
thing and I do not think it's already
that it was important to see that there a good
point is fundamentally the
this quality of user experience
so I think it's important that we
legault clarify the three points but it is
more complicated about navigation is to
who only after having everyone
making a great co-alternative
model to upgrade from zero to
environment that have helped to improve
So here we hangout a
time to talk or talk
specifically in the face of complaints of
get lost get a theme over
a few weeks and will discuss item
specific then s navigation
We can talk about cash after that.
images for example the use of
most important lists that a
ask very good education with bruno
made excellent
We can do this with some
personal question but we party
maybe the last question all letter
time is asking is in
relation to finding the key d link from
spelling of the key
You use to put it in products and
what would be my way of saving the
yet how much can you
just recently I was
working just the example code
dnpm is three but if you say that
You take it as it should, no problem.
is really is the following if you put
It literally gives you lots of
vulnerable to attacks is because you
literally puts there any
Anyone can sort of
discover your code find out which
Are we here and you do not want to do this?
not because the secret key of that key
a public key is is the republic wants
to tell people that they know
she the big problem of the keys is
easily accessible is that someone
could in theory replace
those that public key
by his public key in this way
he could fool his
application thinking that it is that the purchases
that he himself signed was
signed by our key
This is the big problem on the second
literally friends and I stayed
tempted to put a way there in the
code is not an example of how to
that so much grace only that any
I wake up because I put there stays
being standard for example certainly
if there is someone who will want to make a
he will try to make an attack
against any form the example write
that's why I thought it was better
leave the criterion of each one invents the
your own way of photographing find
one of the ways to do it for example
Are you making one in it?
shock with some mode some stream mode
this is very easy to do and effective
another way you can get it from a
way for example I see they signed up
key literally writes it in note
only that evil remains
so football is more the key america
so is the number so I could very much
also to pick up and convert the
the equivalent number to write with the bic
10th congress does not write it later
you convert team gracie purchase
base and 64
Then you get your good name.
I just can not do much, it's just one
way you do not leave that key as
exposed so that's what brings a topic
What is important is that it's very cool.
Why do not you use Xavier? I've already seen one.
genetic implementation in which
I would have to think that so the key chance
and ends up picking up and not doing the
verification of signatures is a terrible
The idea is for him to stay any
anyone who picks their up their ep
and pick up and put a fake account it
and only on the purchase effect
false then it is always important you
use this key and one of the changes that
people did in version 32 in penalty that the
next is now this key for
application is no longer pure savior
it used to be the same for all
applications or even developer and
currently it is specific objective is
much easier this way is
answer to the challenge is at your discretion
how to photograph
I recommend cut into pieces of
make you cry with other stars or
come in one way and another very
important is to make the
code is a code a form that is
easy sorry there to see how it works
make the wheel fix the garnde something
yes to leave can only overshadow the own
customer has integration of the
own director a deck you
but they already have their court and
I see that this case including you
doing this is just set up some
Latin parameters that never used mustache
on the network a little bit before we
You use law, I distanced something.
yes in the guardiola plans
the last question of the world elected here
very interesting sale on map here
that is web that I use the resource to
chip stuck on the floor - now ask for the gps
when they are in a place
closed it is obvious that there would be no opposition
sees gps but would like to know if there is
a way of detecting this absence of
position
So there's no way you do not have a voice.
to detect
given the absence of opposition by the
lack of presence even if your
colleague who is not called knows that the
organization is not available on that
moment I've seen code from the tomb the
inter precisely because of this people
thousands is always the software uses the
software
there's always going to be something there so the
dude go there and get the location ltda one
hot item something already comes out using
itahum inter in the home of the user who
and it will give a no nr will give an error
even worse and show pro and no
time I discovered that it is true is this
and good practice
check the advise I studied you
used in this case is there is nothing that
You have no organization, so this is it.
just then you have to take
care of the wall presumably
Commander spoke the next time you
there is one thing you may not have
mobile is pretty bad you are
for three friends will now have
location it will have network and
users do not have a network organization with
For example, the question is close to a
garage they sometimes do not have
network organization when how much they
are passing through the tunnel
then if it behaves badly when
this happens and only that is that
users
particularly in the case of location is
It always makes sense to you or you use the
best information you have
It's okay that this information can be
some time ago right but not yet
you can call the average expense has
a call to have a call
call new light diet made war
slight tone than that it will return
with the last position that is known from the
not only with the last position
but it will tell you what the accuracy is
of that organization
and how long ago time was there
so if the app what exercised its
user is not an alien is a super
hero
if five minutes ago he was
at an intersection of x and y
minutes later it's not exactly going to be
in another city
So you can you can make you lonely.
need to know how much oil is
to provide relevant messages to you
you know that you do not need
exact location at that time
you know that using the boots cat
chance she has a good concern the
enough you can already provide the
user does not pass the pt if by
do not you have information that is
good enough crf-df east not
block windows returns the user there
a week ago i was in chile
so maybe it's not chile anymore
a week later on the airplanes of all
it is perfectly possible then in this
In case you do your best
application shows in any way the
chile 3 data a company that it
is there because it's the last one you
Just put a little box for him.
saying that the organization is not
available and that is why you are
presenting the data of the last
presentation he is also setting up
console will use gps and things and
putting was in cheese curd cheese
As you like with a lot of stuff.
this is what users can go on play
We did not question the lessons
elections and I'm glad it's all right
even questioning that lesson is only
ok I do not know
for example you need to get your
city ​​or will be able to offer a
delivery service what you say so
Welcome to the city, you do not need
use a specific GPS application
using what can be a city that
need so, so stay tuned
the type of permission request that you
will request a user and always
remember to turn on and off tac as well
only has indicatives unfortunately you
application keeps seeing that glue
week of the location staying up there and
You'll kill shooting app it to
fish or that everyone forgot to
Uncle Uncle to take the update there
also because that
concern with the part of gps only that
this if you use it wrong you can
damage battery including users and
it can hurt you getting caught up a lot
That sort of thing is evident.
unnecessarily you may end up
impairing the use of the experience of
your app also remember too
once again
of those things that we have lists
I do not even know if you're the calculation type.
catching the catar is a fatality one
tragedy, too, because only to
remember once more if you give this detail
also that exists today we came to stay
not seen in the transaction and
The student never locked gps with a
value that can not play that teach
she has this function she had not borrowed
the other thing so the user does not want
wait you user does not want to wait for the
application to do something for more
important that you are doing
the user does not want to wait for more than
It's own time you asked for it.
The user was not expecting us then the worst
thing that happens in application when
type the whole screen is locked
because I'll know that china decided
that has something important to do
now for example reaching 73
the battle will be blocked because he is
the time of ex-users of the
minimum time left in time to use the
application then block the entire law
this is not the same as with
vocalization né
the owner of memory the minute answering
Welcome back, when you ask.
do pedro in relation to 20 recommend a
course you are initiating recommends that the
android training for trainee is there and there
as article 2 of the specific article on the use
from fred timecos
the registration dates still a date of
when you are going to open registration exactly in
Brazil beyond the media
official google brazil and also
When you hear from our blog
just remembering the code brings google.com
sport.com
point br then access fire there
also has our profile in replanting
on our twitter also trying to warn
You guys do not have an exact date yet.
when you are going to open registration
disclosed
we also like the other years
people will keep the broadcasts going
also be able to watch there and the
prepare something special maybe
some cities you've had in the past
who was the man of 60 years possibly
will have something this year also with
the energy company of the region
taking advantage of space if within your
region